yeah that should be the whole review
[Music]
done so Godzilla minus one is the newest
Godzilla film from Japan's Toho Studios
their gift to the world and we thank
them sincerely for this film it takes
place earlier than other Godzilla films
you might be used to this takes place
right after World War II the citizens of
Japan are trying to piece their lives
back together again follows this young
comicy pilot who kind of best I can
phrase it stumbles into a family Dynamic
then Godzilla shows up starts causing
problems okay you can tell from the
intro I really dug this movie I dug it
cuz I'm not nostalgically attached to
Godzilla a lot of stories of people when
they were kids wash a lot of Godzilla
that train missed my childhood entirely
I've seen Godzilla stuff here and there
who hasn't but the consistent Godzilla
entertainment in my life in the past
decade or so has been the Hollywood
Godzilla movies done by legendary
pictures and the first Gareth Edwards
won aside which I did enjoy I I came to
realize I guess Godzilla's just not my
thing Godzilla minus one shows me that I
was wrong to think that what I don't
like are boring Godzilla monster movies
with boring human characters it
concentrates on those boring human
characters thus you have a boring film
case in point Godzilla minus one
concentrates on the human characters and
what you have is a film that
concentrates on a very human story
uh based around love and and the human
Spirit then when Godzilla shows up and
threatens that you have this protective
nature of no that needs to be dealt with
For the Love of the family Dynamic we've
now gotten to know for the love of the
friends circle For the Love of the
country itself that is just starting to
piece itself back together after being
ravaged by World War II it's all a
glorious Dance of the celebration of the
human Spirit which is it's so brilliant
to place Godzilla in this particular
time in Japan's history how is Godzilla
Godzilla in this movie because
Godzilla's been the monster he's been
the anti-hero taken on another monster
uh this is Godzilla is the problem he's
the monster he's the thing that needs to
be dealt with he's he's an [__] which
puts our love and protagonist squarely
on the human characters which again this
movie does an amazing job at getting you
attached to there was always a sense of
danger too you know when Godzilla showed
up I wasn't rooting for the monster I
was actually like I want all my friends
that I've made on this adventure of
watching this movie I want them to live
Godzilla truly did feel like a danger a
threat I was enjoying the time I was
spending with the characters I didn't
want to see their lives possibly be
shattered by the appearance of Godzilla
which is the point it's how was supposed
to be so often in a monster movie I'm
always
like but they can die not here never
felt that not once the effects in this
movie I thought the effects look great
again it doesn't lose that celebration
of old school Godzilla but it is brought
to the Modern Age there are a couple
scenes you can argue look a little rough
around the edges but there are also
scenes in recent Hollywood superhero
movies that have 10 to 20 times the
budget of Godzilla minus one that look
worse quite frankly I was shocked it
only cost $15 million I never once had
that thought of where'd the money go
we've run into that a lot lately you
hear the budgets of some of these
Hollywood movies you're like what who
bought how many Yachts for everybody
where'd that money go as live action
movies ago this was $115 million well
spent a cherry on top his Atomic breath
has never been more epic in any movie
ever featuring Godzilla kind of reminded
me of the Death Star laser in Rogue one
fast concentrated Beam with a nuclear
output all hammered home with the sound
mixing and sound design which yes again
is epic Godzilla sounds terrifying his
destruction is epic and the sound just
puts you in the middle of it I'm just
saying this is the kind of explosion
that would make Christopher Nolan be
like like okay you win the great
cinematic atomic explosion war of 2023
linan Godzilla minus one is a
celebration of Godzilla's Legacy and
shows audiences why this monster has
endured for 70 years but it doesn't do
what we see a lot of movies do which is
just stop there at the Nostalgia Bay
like I said not nostalgically attached
to Godzilla but Godzilla minus one blew
me the [__] away and in the end it all
comes together in a way that I felt was
very filling one of my favorites of the
year uh yes that is to say Godzilla
minus one is awesome
[Music]
tacular yeah this is kind of Godzilla
movie that makes me go okay so let's
watch more Godzilla movies you got to
admit that trailer for Godzilla 2000 I
worked at the theater when we got that
trailer man Godzilla wrecking [__] to
Rob Zombie super beast playing in the
trailer that's got to be Peak Godzilla
trailer right there all right Godzilla
minus one have you seen it what did you
think about it or what are some of the
best Godzilla movies out there top three
top five that sounds pretty good top
five yeah top five Godzilla movies
whatever they are whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
say
[Music]
more